hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and today we are going to hell
I'm sure that some listeners or at least
some people who know about the podcast
have long been convinced that I
personally am going to hell but today
we'll take a slightly more academic or
at least scholarly look at the idea of
what hell is where it came from why it
came to be what's supposed to be going
on there what people think about it
right now
today's guest Mark Devillier is a
Canadian writer he's written non-fiction
books about many different things about
history about politics about the
environment about ecology and for
whatever reason he decided to become
interested in the idea of hell now let
me be very very clear because I know we
have a broad audience this is a
conversation between two people who are
completely convinced that hell is not
real okay we're not actually sitting
down and wondering whether or not hell
might really exist we both kind of take
for granted that it doesn't and I know
that not everyone agrees with that so
apologies if we're not speaking to you
about this issue but from this point of
view of someone who doesn't believe in
Hell the fact that so many people do is
fascinating right why did we invent this
like what was it about human nature that
made us think that there should be a
place where you went to to suffer
eternal torment if you were bad as a
very very dramatic kind of thing and
it's not as if even in the modern world
belief in Hell is is restricted to 2% of
extremists people most people in the
United States believe that hell is real
most religions whether it's not just
Christianity but also Islam Judaism
Hinduism Buddhism most religions in one
form or another has something we would
recognize as hell for that matter
polytheistic religions pagan religions
long before monotheistic religion came
on the scene had this kind of idea so
what brought that about what does it
tell us about human beings and of course
you know it's fun to think about the
psychology the history of the sociology
but there's also a lot of wonderful
little details anecdotes stories right
because hell is a great place to place a
story as we mentioned the podcast
Dante's Inferno is
much more compelling in popular story
than Dante's Paradiso is hell is just
kind of a more interesting compelling
place than heaven is even if you want to
go to heaven and not to hell alright so
we're gonna learn a lot about that I
learned a lot from this you know that as
much as I'm not personally religious the
history of religious thought I think is
both fascinating and important because
it really does tell us something about
human beings and how they perceive of
their own place in the wider cosmos so
let's go
[Music]
Marc de villiers welcome to the
mindscape podcast well thank you for
inviting me this is certainly one of in
my opinion one of those fun topics that
we're gonna be talking about here the
nature the origin the present status of
Hell hell and damnation what what
inspired you to write a book about this
topic well I I'm fascinated by the the
the association between people who are
articulate and they're sensible and the
views that they nevertheless are able to
hold I mean my favorite example was I
did write it put it in the book with
Galileo who is a who has a reputation in
our world anyway as being a you know a
scientist in rebellion against against
obscurity or obscurantism and yet he
spent quite a long while calculating how
far beneath the surface hell would be
based on the notion of Dante's that God
Satan's navel is the actual center of
the earth and the presume size of Satan
and he calculated that hell is therefore
the Dome of hell is there for 650
kilometres beneath the surface of the
earth and he announced these findings in
great triumph to an audience of clerics
and hearing and you know there is an
eminent scientist but nevertheless he
happened to hole it can was able to hold
these these kind of a bizarre and and
contradictory beliefs in the head in his
head at the same time so that's what
interests me most about it I think at
first I didn't know that about Galileo I
knew some other things about Isaac
Newton he'd spent a lot of time on
biblical exegesis later in life and so
forth yeah oh yes Newton was a was
another great scientist who had some
completely lunatic ideas in fact when
you're talking about Galileo it reminds
me you know there's probably plenty of
work being done in modern science which
is of the form if you believe this thing
then let's see the consequences of it
but the thing that you're believing
later we seen down in the future history
to be completely silly yes I think
that's true but you know then I know and
now era of course people are just as
credulous and just as conflicted as they
were there I mean I read this morning
that Joe Biden was now a speaker
jihadist is pausing to take over the
government of the U of S I didn't know
that it is that part of his new plan
yeah
it's not part of this press release but
you know there Chris furniture could
spiritual theorists who can believe
almost anything yeah and it is a
fascinating thing that was why the very
first episode of mindscape that I did
was with Carol Travers a social
psychologist and we talked about why how
people can justify their untrue beliefs
well yeah but today we're talking about
what some of the subjects of those
beliefs are so I do want to get you know
into the origin story of hell and so
forth but let's just get our bearings
with a quick survey of the present
situation like how many people believe
in Hell is it is it Universal among
religions or well there are almost all
religions have a hell or many hell's and
some of this some of the Burmese health
for example they are forty thousand and
forty hell's in Burmese and Buddhism one
for each sin and obviously some of those
sins are going to be fairly trivial
because I mean for example borrowing
books and not giving them back
pretending you've lost them has its own
hell no I find a bit of reasonable but
you know and and people who lie about
the ages when they get married has its
own hell people who throw broken pottery
of offenses has its own hell and there
seems in Chinese Buddhism it seems a
little unfair but people with irregular
teeth have their own hell too which
seems really unfair
it does seem unfair well unless it's
their own fault for bad dental hygiene
yeah well that's true
I mean summarize we have the story from
the New Testament where where Jesus kept
casting out demons from people and and
there were a lot of demons in the New
Testament
Jesus's homeland seemed to be thick on
the ground women and and these one says
we know the gallery is 20 he cast his
demons out into a intuition just into
poor pigs yeah which seems again really
unfair and would certainly get Peter on
his case these days what did I think
edible cruelty people yeah so okay so
good almost all religions have it or the
individual just today just again to get
our bearings are most religious
believers buying into this in most
recent Gallup poll people who believed
in religion in the United States had
actually increased in the last decade or
so from from somewhere around forty five
to eight somewhere right approaching 60
percent more people accuracy believed in
hell then actually believe in heaven
which is seemed to me and an indication
of this the peculiar nature of American
politics as it's tough in Canada where I
live the the belief in hell is less
thirty to thirty five percent believe in
Hell where almost everybody believes in
heaven so we're more optimistic we'll
drop a bit that we can draw okay so
virginity in Europe also more people
believe in Hell than believe in heaven
these days which is I find nursing so
it's both sort of Universal between
religions and at least a healthy
fraction of people in all the religions
actually buy into it so help that book
yeah yeah yeah we're we're chuckling
here at this belief but this is very
very widely held
yes it's very widely held and and it's
interesting it's cross religion almost
every religion with some exceptions some
interesting exceptions believe in Hell
and even those religions such as most
variants of Buddhism which don't have a
heaven believe in hell and some of the
Buddhist hell's are grotesque grotesque
in their litany of punishments if
somehow some people for example the the
Hebrews and the modern Jews they have a
they're not very good at hell
I mean Jews are good at many things
presumably but I'm not very good at
he'll enjoy fellows are really boring
everybody
to show and and everybody good or bad
evil or virtuous they all go to the same
place and the Jewish faith is more
interested in the here and now than in
the after world which I that's been my
emotion if they don't have a quite
nearly the detailed picture of what
comes after as Christians or Muslims do
know because there's no there's no
belief in the in the eternality of the
soul for one thing so when you're dead
you're dead and that's so it's better to
concentrate on the on the here now then
there are where you might be after the
candle is snapped out to you yeah well
so I really liked the part of your book
where you talk about some of the origins
of Hell and and more generally in the
afterlife right it sort of crept up on
us in some way there was first some
belief in that there was some kind of
afterlife and then it could have kind of
got elaborated on as time went by I
think where it started probably was in
the early animist days when people
needed an explanation of why things
didn't work why a perfectly competent
hunter you know fella was killed by a
perfectly normal and an aggressive
animal there had to be a reason for that
okay it just doesn't happen and
therefore demons came into the into the
equation as an explanation for things
going wrong so then this I think the
second thread of Hell was it seemed that
life became it seemed in urban when
civilization moved into the urban sphere
even the era that life seemed unfair and
it seemed that that murderers and
adulterers and embezzlers who should be
punished seem to prosper much more than
then seemed you know decent and so you
had to find some way of finding out a
way to punish them when they were there
it had to be after were dead because
they're quite clearly nobody was
punishing in while I was here yeah so
that's another way of inventive
inventing there's another reason for
hell I think the third trend of why
people invented hell was as what a
former Episcopal bishop spawn called
soul control which is basically a way of
imposing discipline on the adherents
your religion and and threatening them
with punishment when they didn't follow
the injunctions of the hierarchy so
though I think those three things
together in a modern more modern version
of Hell this they are slightly
contradictory because if it's a place of
punishment and therefore Satan and the
devil are agents of justice or it's a
way of sort of ordinary citizens it's
sort of getting their own back which
Satan isn't is it you know an agent of
God in that sense yeah and but on the
other hand many of our religion
particular see Anna T portray satan as
the willful and rebellious angel of God
called Lucifer who was punished and
banished and into the pit prepared for
him and so you have this contradictory
things where Satan is either a victim of
his own hubris as I put it in the book
he seemed to be a an ambitious lad
trying to take over the family business
from dad where was the God and or or he
was he was he was either bag or he was
an agent holding the evildoers to
account and and the monotheism's have
not really got this sorted out the
internal contradictions yeah I mean it's
part of there's a whole we will get into
this I think but there are once you have
these supernatural beings with enormous
power and you try to use them as
explanatory agents there are sorts of
contradictions that you run into right
and and the devil being both useful to
the cosmic battle and also you know an
agent of mischief is definitely one of
those
it's expressed by you know in many of
the of the kind of establishment views
of Hell in Christianity like Dante's for
example most famous where Satan is at
the inner most pit of hell imprisoned in
ice and there for eternity and yet
somehow he is able to roam the universe
fomenting mischief and and with malice
aforethought so how these two things
play out is is in most denominations
aligned in really because they don't
really want to think about the
contradictions too much but the idea of
Hell as a punishment I get I got the
impression from your book that that sort
of was a later addition to the idea that
there were there was an afterlife right
in Greek mythology and so forth there
was still an afterlife but it was not
punitive in the same sense that's right
what it sorry
even the going very early into
civilization the ancient ancient ancient
Egyptians believed in an afterlife and
you had to as it's predictable in Europe
in Egypt you had to get their bike by
floating down a river and crossing
through gates and so on but those who
fail to make the cut and there was a
being called the devourer of souls who
were standing by to to grab hold of
those people who fail to prove their
virtue virtuousness but he just devour
this off a lat test if you would an able
to pass the gates they you simply
disappeared there was no there was no
punishment you were just you were just
dead you were ended and what was the
nature of the test was it a moral virtue
test or yes yes and they were there were
there were judges who assess how you had
behaved during your lifetime and who
there were people who exempt from this
test and those were the no surprise here
the priests caste and the royal family
you didn't they didn't have to be they
were automatically assumed to be virtual
very clever yeah nice head
and though that same attitude was
adopted by many of the of the later
cultures in the early miss attempt
Mesopotamian culture like Goguryeo tech
culture and the canonized pretty much
had the same thing when you were dead
you you you you went to a place prepared
for you but there was no punishment that
you were just there and in most cases
you said after waters and we died and
the same thing was in Oh the old African
cultures which are particularly a form
of where you became a if you were good
you came a revered ancestor and if you
didn't they to be to be forgotten by the
living was the worst hell enough
you were just somebody dead then it's
probably impossible to answer but do
people at least speculate about you know
who was the first person to suggest that
life continued after death or you know
where did that idea pop up on the scene
it's very early I mean we know it goes
back to at least 3,000 BC in the in the
ancient Egyptian cultures the Kosovo
Cyrus was one of the earliest and Sidney
that goes back this and there's a lot of
speculative evidence but speculative
recorded evidence but speculations
anyway that the early Stone Age caused
to the hunter-gatherer cultures and also
believed that they were that they were
it was able to you were able to survive
yes if you succeeded in a series of
assigned tasks and those tasks were
dictated by your IO family and also your
tribe and your clan and so I think the
notion that there was a that you didn't
die went back almost as early as as the
search for causality in the universe as
a search for the reason why things
happened it must have been a reason for
something it must be a reason for
Thunder really and regards stomping
across the crowd so it was a fairly
short step from that to believing that
they were
natural beings to believing that well
under the right circumstances we could
join them yeah and I mean certainly so
what's interesting there is that even
before we officially had hell as
distinct from heaven we had this idea of
judging right like it's it's very clear
that the whole set up is very much in
response to human beings desire to find
reasons why things happen and justice
and fairness in dealing with them
somehow if we can't do it here on earth
let's say that the afterlife takes care
of it that's right exactly and and you
have to rely on the judges to deeply
know the inner lives of the the souls
who appeared before them and they would
know if you sin during your life and
they would know how you sinned and they
would know whether you were repented and
they would judge you accordingly and in
the ancient Greek Hades the mythology of
Hades there were there were three levels
it was a fields of asphodel which were
everybody went while they're waiting for
the judge and then there was Elysium
which which you went to if you were
judged to be a virtuous and then they
were Tartarus which was the innermost
pit and flames of hell and Hellfire and
that's where that's where the it were
from the the the Greeks would develop
this notion that torture was very much a
part of the afterlife the Egyptians in
and they wouldn't need that they they
sometimes in later dynasties in Egypt
people were cut up and flayed and boiled
and winston's you know and skinned and
everything but it wasn't the point
wasn't a punishment the point was just
to get Ian's dead in a week
the Greeks developed us into a much more
systematic thing and and so but even the
Greeks didn't have it or eternity you
could you could probably that was left
to the Christians and the monotheism is
to introduce the notion that that hell
was an ending that eternity was part of
the formula oh that's interesting I mean
I guess it makes sense I hadn't realized
that but in the
shift from polytheism to monotheism a
lot of things that were finite become
infinite in some way right like you had
a bunch of flawed individuals being your
gods in polity polytheism and then
everything is sort of perfect and
everlasting up there in the sky or down
below once you get a monotheistic and in
polytheism they had these corals and
families of gods and what happened to
you could could swerve and turn on its
heel if a different God was prevailed on
a different day yeah so if it storm God
was was better than the god of
Agriculture your crops failed on the
other hand in some cases the god of
Agriculture was able to put the storm
garden into a hole where he belonged and
your crops were wonderful and so so it
was it was you it was easy to explain
why things went wrong because it's
whatever whatever happened one God or
other prevailed over another and the
quarrelsome families of gods were
constantly at war with each other and so
that made sense when it when it when the
the ancient Hebrews invented them honor
theism no longer made sense that because
God was it was infinitely able and
infinitely it alas wasn't was
everlasting and he was therefore
impossible for him to be wrong
yeah and therefore what happened what
had to happen is that we were wrong we
weren't we weren't worship worshipping
him or adhering to his ways in the
proper fashion and therefore he was
right to punish us so but it was not the
God's fault anymore it was our fault
now and but nevertheless there is some
universality in the idea right I mean so
the Greeks came up with Tartarus
Tantalus Tartarus sagar torturous
Tartarus was the place Tantalus was a
person right was that yes that's right
yes okay but still the hindus the
buddhists i think that japanese folk
religion and so forth also came up with
this idea that you would be treated
badly afterward if you were bad and
while you're alive well I both the Hindu
and the Buddhist traditions the hell was
not was not open-ended for obvious
reasons because the reason he went there
was not for punishment the reason you
were sent there was to work through the
sins that you committed in life and once
you had purged those from your system
and the best way of purging them was to
be tortured for millennia and that would
certainly drive all thoughts of sin out
of your mind I would think after a short
while and and but you were you you were
then released on parole
you were let out to start your life
again and this could last for a very
long time in the Hindu traditions at the
time you spent in hell varied from
somewhere like 400 to 500 thousand years
to several million it seemed like must
have seemed like eternity to those
people who were consigned there but it
wasn't forever right and the same with
them with the Buddhist traditions there
was a old tradition in Tibetan Buddhism
for example where a mountain of sesame
seeds a hundred miles on a saw hide a
cube and one small bird took one seed
away every thousand years and when that
mountain had disappeared then you were
you were deemed to have purged your sins
and you could be released well okay this
brings up a question I'm definitely
gonna ask although let's get out of the
way right now I mean how do they come up
with this but a specific idea you know
it's someone had to invent that at some
point and do you think that they were
they knew they were just inventing it or
do they think that they were working it
out did they think that there was a
revelation
I think this remains this remains a
mystery because it's it's a the same
level of opportunity that that we've we
still face with now when we're faced
with a supernatural it
they had to be a story's started and
then they became embellished and one
monastry was competing with another and
one monk was telling tales that were
more up-to-date and more modern and more
lurid than the previous monk and I think
there was a competitiveness in in what
we would now call it I sent fake news
that they are duly charged with but
nobody in nobody knows who actually
invented these I mean it Buddha himself
somebody accepted them as as real and he
had a long listing of the tortures
rather enthusiastic distinct of the
tortures to which sinners would be
subjected and but he also liked like all
of his followers believed that in the
end karma would would prevail and you
would be able to work your way through
your sins and purify yourself and then
you would it would be bathed in the
river of forgetfulness and you would
start the whole process again and that
could weird but where the endless
numbers of millenia came from I think
they were just out there was a Japanese
monk again Shin who was a who had as I
suggested in the book only a hazy idea
of cosmological time who suggested that
10 trillion years might be about right
for the average sinner to escape and
nobody as far as I know has top that I
guess some cosmologists on the scene I
think I think we can top that but I mean
I also wonder whether the audience for
these stories at the time didn't take
them seriously right like ok sesame
seeds etc now now we are imagining that
it was you know doctrine handed down
from on high but at the time it was just
a fun story I think I think but to those
both of those aspects are correct I
think it was a story that they could be
thrilled we
and also it was a way of inculcating in
people who succeeded them their children
and their families a way of threatening
them with with the punishment if they
didn't shape up right so I think both of
those things happen anyway
I think that almost certainly nobody
thought to myself taught himself oh you
know my god if I don't behave now I'm
gonna be in there for two trillion years
I don't think anybody actually thought
they just said I you know it's gonna be
it's going to be so yeah you know yeah
it's gonna be bad and the Hellfire is
gonna ya be in the knives in and and I'm
going to be immersed in noxious and
obscene liquids and yeah it's gonna be
bad but I'll get on get out of it and I
think they different you believe that
something was going to happen yeah but
the official so they were definitely
stories being told but there's also I
mean some of those stories were stories
of about eyewitness testimony right
there's a tradition of visiting hell
that you know the ancient Greeks had
Orpheus and so forth and the Christians
have done a story Aeneas was there and
if you look at the medieval period which
is where most of these most lurid
imaginings of Hell came from in
Christianity it seemed at one point is
virtually every literate monk or nun had
either visited hell or had been
vouchsafed hell in a vision or I talked
to somebody who was there and could
vouch for the veracity of everything and
the stories were actually remarkably
similar no sir
I guess not remark I'm not surprising me
because they they fed off each other but
Pitts Pitts dark gloomy pits Hellfire
that gave off no light fire that burned
but didn't destroy you couldn't just how
if I couldn't destroy people because I
would be beside the point it would be
over too soon
right so it had to burn you but you
couldn't die on it and there was a you
know there are in some versions of some
of the visions many of the visions of
hell there were very sharp big crows who
standing by to drag your entrance out
through your anus and you with well it's
similar adversity for sure and you know
you think okay well after a while I
wouldn't you sort of run out no he had
some entrails apparently not this these
sisters were endlessly self-renewing and
that's part of the interesting and
peculiar physics of the nether world and
if you can go visit light as Aeneas and
Orpheus and virtual may be it has to be
located somewhere right I thought was
very funny in your book like you go
through like all the places where hell
might be found I you it wasn't nearly as
conceptual as you might think of it
today you might actually find the
entrance if you look hard enough oh yes
with the medieval Romans knew exactly
where it was just off about Etna and
it's there's a is a grotto there which
gives off for to court befitting gases
which are poisonous gases and and people
notice that birds accrue past it or net
cows and wander into it keeled over then
and so that obviously was a place where
it was the anteroom to hell and it was
inhabited by one of the nasty symbols
and Gorgons and so that was one but
there were many others there were one in
a Werdum there was one in in Greece
there was also one in many stone and as
I said a johnny-come-lately hell it was
thought to be beneath the law turkey in
Ireland because st. Patrick founded
there and reported that he had been he
had been given it to poor and there many
others there's a there's one of the
coast of the west side of the Gulf of
Mexico
the Aztecs had an interesting hello
there
but above every popular one is in China
and the city of fondue which was visited
by
numberous numerous people and Governor
Cuomo of the promises or
was lowered into it on a rope and he
spent a nice time in hell and was a was
given a nice cup of tea while they
explained the management of the system
to him and the city of fungus has been
known actually for 1500 years it's been
a repository of hellish law the origins
of fondue are widely thought to be a
prosperous because they're manufactured
instruments of torture which they then
sold that the denizens of the underworld
and unfortunately who was a drowned in
the rising of the waters of the Three
Gorges Dam so that but they still have a
theme park there which you visit you
know like I suppose if howls down there
why should we be surprised that there's
multiple entrances to it right you know
I mean it just makes things easier but
be efficient right and there's almost
always a gate it's a gated community
yeah like like like heaven is generally
and you have to yeah Jeff
Dante is famous injunction you know lose
all hope ye who pass through here but
almost all the the ancient Egyptians had
seven gates the Zoroastrians had eight I
think if I recall correctly and pretty
well everybody had at least one gate you
had to pass through the legend of Ishtar
is sending it to the underworld to visit
her sister she had to pass with eight
gates and losing an item of clothing and
everyone she was forced to appear before
her sister who was a thoroughly
unpleasant goddess called rescue girl
who impaled Ishtar and a meat hook until
the gods and above came and rescued her
so yeah the always gates and sometimes
their bridges you have to cross in order
to get into hell are these gates keeping
people out or in always keeping people
out because you when your time has come
you you you you couldn't go it
you couldn't enter hell until your time
was really except a nearest was able to
do
to go in and of course dante was able to
use virgil to get him in so there were
there were passwords you could use as
people you could use that were they were
able to get you in but nobody ever tried
to escape because you couldn't you
couldn't get out that wasn't part of the
plan it's interesting they would try to
keep people out I am very interested in
how the specificity of alls I mean
obviously in someone like Dante it
becomes huge but as you mentioned in the
book the if you read the Jewish Bible
the Old Testament there's almost no talk
of Hell or Satan or anything like that
and there's more of it in the New
Testament and even more in the Quran and
so people that we became more interested
in the details along the way I think as
it as hell in Christianity became more
embedded in the system
the further away from Christ we got the
more grotesque the punishments of hell
became and it but it wasn't really until
the mid early medieval pay at times when
the church was beginning to face
competition from early free thinkers and
also later on of course from Calvin and
Luther and they were felt themselves to
be under attack by by people who were
not as controlled as I should be at that
point hell became even more severe and
Satan turned from a agent of God and a
guardian of the dead into something evil
and malevolent who would would grasp you
if you didn't behave if you didn't
adhere to the tenets of the church if
you didn't listen to your bishop if you
didn't be you know follow that the
threads that they were told that they
told you to and if you were if you were
a protestor or Protestant as it became
later then Hellfire would good would get
you for sure and the closer it's the
same syndrome as in witch trials of
Europe in the 17th and 18th century
became more and more aggressive the more
that the church felt itself under attack
from from dissenters and so there's no
wonder for example in Germany where many
of those early dissenters and began
there were more which is a burned and
hanged in Germany than in any other
place so it's it's predictable that the
hierarchy of the church exaggerated and
made more appalling the punishments that
awaited you if you didn't adhere to the
proper way of doing things if you we
just stuck to the New Testament or even
just to the Gospels can we say anything
about what the early church or what
Jesus would have thought about hell I
mean I think there's some debate right
and whether Jesus that's clear that
Jesus had in the Gospels had very little
say about hell there were a couple of
things when Matthew quoted him as saying
that that you know people that certain
people would be consigned into the
eternal flames and Jesus was big on that
on the kind of weddings and gnashing of
teeth that went on down hell but he
never said where it was and he never
said much about who went that who didn't
in in those hell at that point was
really a according to those stories was
really an imprisoning place for the
opponents of God and it was mostly Satan
not so much humans and it was really
only as the church grew in its stature
and got further away from the writers of
the gospel and the and the the the say
the supposed sayings of Jesus himself
that they started to invent the more
aggressive punishment that sinners would
face if they didn't follow the the Holy
Church Jesus did talk about heaven quite
a bit right in how he needed to go yeah
need to go through him to get through
and maybe just assume that the that not
getting into heaven meant you went to
hell I think that was the assumption and
certainly the early church believed that
anyone who is not just didn't follow
Jesus or was born before Jesus existed
would automatically be consigned to hell
and in fact one of the stories has Jesus
doing these harrowing of hell that is
visiting hell after he was crucified on
some versions why they were still on the
cross going down and rescue people like
Adam and the first people who are who in
hell because they came before him but he
got them out and he was able to get them
out
so yeah everybody who wasn't saved by
Jesus would be automatically consigned
to hell yeah I mean this is a
fascinating story to me it comes into
one of the sets of contradictions
you know it's somehow in the history
religion there are certain things you
want to be true and it might be
difficult to make everything compatible
with everything else so the harrowing of
hell story is right there in the gospel
or at least in one of the get which book
it is yeah there's no there's no real
detail most of the real stories about
the hello a harrowing of hell were from
the apocryphal Gospels or some of the
Gnostic Gospels right for example the
gospel of nicodemus and gossamer
Bartholomew which were rejected by the
early church fathers and not
incorporated into the Canon that's where
most of these stories of the harrowing
of hell came from and there were also
some early versions of the stories which
were in fact pre hell the thing called
the testimony of truth which is one of
the Gnostic Gospels had stood it's whole
tale of Adam and Eve and and original
sin on its hand and in that sense the
gospel was very critical of God for for
for grudging Adam and Eve knowledge why
would he do that what a malicious grudge
he was as the gospel put it and in that
case the the serpent or Satan was
portrayed as the sensible worldly person
in God with it was a kind of a peevish
person simply punishing people who
didn't listen to him properly so there
was a lot of variance on that but in the
in the actual Gospels that are in the
New Testament there's actually very
little about hell I mean maybe it's
worth for those who don't know about
this whole story maybe it's worth just
talking a little bit about how
what we now consider to be descriptors
came together right it wasn't like there
was one very clean process by which
either the Hebrew Bible or the New
Testament we were just written down they
were whole bunch of documents floating
around and some councils had to decide
what was in and what was out but the
people at the time you know it might
have read all these stories whether
nothing they did I think they probably
did did read many of them and also the
ancient prophecies Hebrew prophets were
much more into apocalyptic visions then
the then the you know the Sanhedrin or
the Hebrew authorities were and a lot of
those survived and and were transmuted
into into stories that were wood picked
up by the Christians and also
Christianity adopted freely from
Zoroastrianism which was which had a
very well-developed
dualistic theory of a universe it was in
contention between the forces of virtue
and the forces of evil and that was one
of the first monotheistic religions that
really goes on yes it was the first
first it was for multinational
monotheistic religion I think and
Christianity picked up a lot of its
thoughts about Hell from Zoroastrianism
from the Greek mythologies of Hades from
their stories of the torches of
Prometheus and in having his liver
pecked out for eternity by a vulture and
so and these source accreted as like as
they went along and then as the as the
early few centuries of Christianity
proceeded they tended to a agglomerate
some of the earlier stories and
accumulate them and embellish them and
by the time you got to the seventh and
eighth century a time of Charlemagne for
example this the visions of hell had
become reasonably predictable that there
was a it was a beneath the earth it was
a they were cauldrons of boiling oil
there was Hellfire
there were demons with the pitchforks
and those were worked into almost all of
the the visions that followed in the
next few few centuries except the Satan
who became more and less and less a
servant of God and more and more a
creature of evil as we proceeded through
the centuries
well Satan story is more complex I think
that most people think certainly it's
more complex than I knew until I read
your book there there is for one thing
there's the idea of Hades which was
originally the person and then it became
a place that with maybe with a person
and then there's like old bosses at
different times and you know good very
confusing because petrology is not
simple yeah Hades was first of all a
place and then yes Hades also became the
the god the god of the underworld his
brothers reserves and Poseidon and he
drew drew the short straw and drew the
underworld and it was always regarded as
a horrendous to look at and pitiless and
monstrous and which I argue in the book
was a bit of a bum rap because he was
he's a his brothers were just as bad
I mean his family was not an exemplary
family his father who fathered all this
is one of the Titans Kronos swallowed
Hades and some of his siblings when they
were infants and zeros showing some of
the leadership skills that made him a
chief god later on force his father to
vomit up and the children and rescued
them and then the children banded
together and prepared a pit for the
Titans and banished their father into
this pit and there was the earliest
version of the underground place to
store the bad guys right family is
always hard yeah yeah and so the early
Christian hell early versions of
Christian hell started more as the same
way as a revolt against God Lucifer and
his cohorts were were
rebellious we're not taking orders and
God in a you know a fit of anger again
sent the Asian Angela and Gabrielle to
prepare a pit for for Lucifer which was
basically borrowed Hollis bolus from the
Greeks it was the same story just
updated with new names and and that's
where and that's why and that's where
Satan came from and he was abolished if
you if you listen to Milton and people
from the patricians he born not only was
Lucifer abortion but about half the
heavenly host went with him so as I said
in the Mucca doesn't show much for God's
management skills and half of his crowd
was a revolt against it
but anyway and so both the ancient Greek
hell and the more modern house started
with a revolt in heaven but Hades and
and and Satan were often in many early
Christian writings cohabiting nor
coexisting in in in Hell Hades was the
ruler of hell and Satan was the prince
of death and sometimes they work
together and sometimes they didn't and
there was a there was a fair amount of
quarrels quarreling going on and there
was some yeah I mean there was one
gospel of bartholomae was wonderful in
the that's just depicting the the panic
and the ineffectual nests of both Satan
in Hades when Jesus came to her rescue
Adam and and they kept blaming each
other for inviting him down there
horseplay it was it doesn't say it
doesn't again they've seen more
ineffectual old fractures and they
didn't skilful evil managers of the dead
but the early Christians thought that
like you said both Satan and Hades were
powerful figures in hell as far as I can
tell Hades has disappeared from the
official doctrine yes Hades disappear
sometimes he crops up as a the name bill
Zebub
okay but that that is beautiful was
derived from the the Mesopotamian God
Baal who
also visited the hell did wrestle with
deaf at some point but it's it's very
confusing because there's no consistency
bill Zebub to sometime Haiti sometimes
it's Lucifer himself Hades was
originally the the master of Hell and
later on was consigned to a lesser role
as a kind of innkeeper in chief and
after a while he just vanished from the
as the as the Romans the Roman religion
was supplanted by Christianity Hades and
the other pantheon of the Greek gods
disappeared and and I came faded into
the background and it's not even clear
the relationship between Lucifer and
Satan is that right well no I think it's
pretty clear that Lucifer is Satan again
there are contradictions in the stories
and then the other version of Satan is I
mean Satan is as you probably know
already in Hebrew simply means adversary
so we're adversary and he was a he was
originally a one of the servants of God
and he was the one who goaded God into
for example a testing lot with this with
the boils that he will and try putting
him through the trials of his faith and
was Satan and God who cooked up this
little scheme together so here was a lot
or job we're talking about a job I'm
sorry Joe yeah Joe and and Satan was
really on the on the in the Royal Court
he was one of one of the children of God
so yes he was also Lucifer and he was
Satan at the same time and it was there
were two quite separate quite separate
views of Hell that developed the
Christians turned him into Satan and
lost a Lucifer and some of the early
Christians thought well Lucifer could
easily be redeemed he wasn't so bad he
had a bad press you couldn't he could be
saved and and this was just this was it
was a minority view that was punished by
exile and and casting in MO and people
like or again for example who was an
early Christian and you had to fly and
one of these contradictions that you
mentioned is the idea that in in in most
of the stories at least as they
developed in the Christian telling hell
predates humankind is that right like
the falls Lucifer and so forth happened
first and and it was like I said used as
a prison for the bad angels and then
repurposed I guess as a place where
people it's essentially what it was and
there was it was it was basically the
what they call the inner most pit which
is where Satan and Lucifer and Satan aka
Lucifer and he is a cohort we're in
prison and originally was just a hole in
the ground which and God instructed
Gabriel to keep sharp rocks on their
head and keep them in down in there so
it was a pretty primitive arrangement
which is a pit with rocks and that
became much more embellished as time
went on and it didn't seem sufficient
that there would be a that Satan was
just imprisoned in there with nothing
much to do and you needed some how to
deal with sinners you needed somewhere
to control their actions you didn't want
to let them enter into anymore heresies
and then you could then you could head
off and so yes it became in your word
repurposed into a into a a prison for
malefactors and not just a prison for
the the chief rams devil in chief yet I
mean the Christians certainly had a good
time embellishing and complicating the
the notion of hell did Judaism not do
that I mean it was not a big deal
certainly in the Old Testament times but
was there some tradition in Judaism also
coming up with some stories about the
afterlife as after the Babylonian
captivity has people returned to Israel
there were developments in the in this
universal notion of Judaism that
everybody just went to show and it
was a place where there was no activity
there was nothing to eat nothing to do
with your dog and Ruby and after a while
the same impulses came into the Judaic
thought that somehow evildoers would
prospering more than they should and so
sure became divided into two a place for
this sinners in a place for the virtuous
and it was a fairly short would be a
fairly short step from there for the
evildoers be punished and there and the
virtuous to be rewarded and indeed there
were some streams in Judaism that
believed and to some degree and some
sectors still believed that that there
would be a that when the Messiah comes
and Abram is resurrected that those
virtuous would be accepted into a world
which was a more Michalek and more yeah
Paradiso cand the sinners would
therefore just be forgotten and not not
killed and not tortured but just
forgotten forgotten whereas on the other
side of things Islam comes along at a
time when the idea of Hell is already
pretty fully developed and as far as I
can tell they they took to it
enthusiastically enthusiastically and
they have a number of rather in
inventive embellishments the the diet of
of of Hell is there's a particular route
which you feel poorest from the SAP if
you poured a drop of the sample of the
earth it would poison all life on Earth
well the sinners were forced to drink
that and and and of course they
destroyed and then there were
resurrected immediately afterwards also
they were very good on Muhammad himself
was very good on those ways that you
could in fact torture people without
them dying boring incredibly hot boiling
liquid on top of their heads and then it
would run through the body and pull out
at their feet
that was one of his favorites
and then of course once it was out you
would be resurrected and the whole
process would start all over again so
but diet was a was much more an
interesting and a facet of Islamic Hill
than I didn't see anything and anybody
had done to anybody who suggested what
you might actually eat nobody nobody got
that far with Islam was big was good on
that and he'll go ahead no I mean in
Hellfire the Christian fires still
remain the hottest furnaces of all Islam
used fire consistently and mostly to
burn off the skin there was what they
were interested in and just not much
into mincing and cutting then there was
left for the the Buddhists to get into
that sort of thing and the Christians
get into boiling in oil but they were
like flaying was part of her and what
the Islamic thought would be appropriate
punishment in hell and I would imagine
that in any of these mature religions
there's both a set of stories and things
that people tell each other and then
there's sort of the official doctrine I
mean how much of this specific story of
Hell and you know who is the boss in it
and who lives there and what happens to
you there is embedded and I mean the
Catholics are probably the best at
writing things down right but it's but
even so there's very little it's it's
not in the in the in the Catechism and
it's not in the official doctrines of
the Catholic Church but in the writings
of of the Jesuits of the writings of
early bishops Allen I have known for
example it was a famous Irish or a
bishop of the of the I think the 7th
century the the embellishments came
outside the Canon generally and so they
adopted from each other they adapted
from each other and they embellished on
each other another's work and it but
very little was in the category the
Catechism of the Catholic Church itself
does say that hell is an actual place
where
your son isn't going to be actually
tortured but they don't get into the
specifics of it that's left for the
commentary commentary it and wasn't
there a rumor going around that Pope
Francis had mentioned to an interviewer
that maybe hell wasn't in fact literal
that way yeah I think the Catholic
Church has backed away from this I mean
it's silly the Catechism but but Francis
for example said that hell is simply a
radical separation from God which is a
much more intellectual and and not
physical version of par not so much
burning there not so much burning there
no it was self torture in a sense and it
he vatican rapidly backpedal when he was
quoted as saying this through an italian
journalist but it wouldn't have
surprised anybody if he had said it the
the hierarchy is is skeptical of the
literal interpretations of gospel these
days and and there should be the view it
should be interpreted in to some degree
as metaphor as some degree and as
excessive exploration but not going to
be taken as literally as it used to be
taken I think that's quite common in in
the Catholic Church yes even now so I
did I actually did research for this
podcast interview that is to say I went
onto Google and I asked what the current
beliefs were it's easy to find you know
opinion polls at least in the u.s.
worldwide it's been a different story
but yeah so what I found was that right
now 72% of Americans believe in heaven
it's may be falling very very slowly but
it's not significant 58 percent are
believing in hell and that's been
consistent for at least 10 years but I
think it is higher than it used to be
and interestingly so 58 percent of
Americans believe in hell but among
American Buddhists it's 32 percent among
American Hindus it's 28 percent and
among Americans who don't have a
religious affiliation it's 27 percent
yes that's astonishing thing you could
even hello if you're not religious yeah
it certainly serves some purpose there
because it's very convenient it's a
convenient
concept Java to have a hell because it
explains so much well and 70% of
Americans believe in Satan and that is
apparently up from only 55% a couple
decades ago the for whatever reason
belief in Satan is skyrocketing in the
United States well they're people who
look around and see what's going on in
the country believe that some malevolent
force must have a hand in it somewhere
otherwise why would it be everything be
so crazy you know they they it's gotta
be some explanation some reason for it
and Satan even if you don't believe in
Hell Satan is a malevolent force
patrolling the universe it doesn't
necessarily have to have a home right
but he is he is a force that's a
countervailing force to the to the
positive force of what you have you call
it God and Jesus spiritualism Buddha
Yama whatever your particular religion I
was trying to figure out whether I
should be surprised
whether it's easier to believe in hell
without Satan or to believe in Satan
without hell probably it's easier to
believe in Satan without how I would
think so because hell is such there's so
so much specific detail about what it is
what it looked like what the meteorology
is like and what the topography is like
and and and and and the imps and demons
and run it have to have a hierarchy it's
a very complicated thing where Satan
just as a is a malicious spirit who
couldn't be could be manifest anywhere
and at any time in any person so yeah I
think it's much easier to believe in the
devil than it is to believe in his abode
and believing in Satan certainly does
help you know make monotheism a little
bit more consistent with our experience
of the world right if there were just a
single omnipotent benevolent God and no
other powerful supernatural creatures he
has a lot of explaining to do well it's
it's one of the cure of the difficulties
of monotheism's and difficulties of
believing and
in a universal loving and just gone is
the explanation for evil and therefore
Satan is a very convenient explanation
for that it's never quite worked out why
and all-powerful all-seeing and all of
lipid in God has allowed the force of
evil and the force of evil to appear and
to compete with them the theory is that
a in in a in a sense
Satan is God's creation and because it
it helps to impose discipline and
explain things that God Himself is
unable to do and so he's acting as God's
agent in that sense yeah so just letting
some of my personal opinions leak in
here I'm sorry I've been doing it the
whole hour but I'll do it even more
explicitly here yes there's the problem
of evil in religion if God is good and
omnipotent why is there evil in the
world and like so many other attempts to
answer these conundrums in the context
of religious belief the idea that well
there's also Satan and that helps
explain the existence of evil seems more
like a deferral than a solution right
well it doesn't explain anything it the
explanation is just one step removed why
Satan causes have been what caused Satan
same argument when they're people
arguing for the existence of God there
has to be a God because who caused the
universe well then you know who caused
God exactly yeah if evil exists what
caused evil will Satan cause evil what
why is Satan exists because core God's
cause Satan yeah and there must be a
reason why God did that and the reason
is they're evilly evil happens anyway
and it seems that God is not as
omnipotent and all-powerful as as the
doctrine suggests so I think one of the
reasons why we came in contact is
because you wrote this book and I
provided a blurb for it and that's
because I was quoted in it
and yeah the reason why I was quoted in
it is because there was this discussion
started by a New York Times column by
Ross Douthat yeah where he is making the
argument which he's not the first to
make that without the notion of hell
there's no reason to be a good person
without the the concept of punishment
afterward anything goes and that's bad
yes I think it's quite common and that's
a very it's a very condescending view of
human life it seems to me because if if
you're automatically going to be evil
and this is a controlling force that
forces you to be good it doesn't say
much for your for your spiritual
development it doesn't say much for your
personality doesn't say much for your
society in which you're embedded and it
seems that why should we have why should
people automatically choose to do bad
things if there's not a control over
their or their activities it's a it
seems that you know why does why does
Ross doubt why do people like Ross doubt
it
think that you're going to automatically
be evil if you're not forced to be good
why is what if you're a good Christian
and you originally believed in a god why
couldn't the reverse be true why
couldn't you be good unless you're being
forced to be evil but they don't seem to
confront that they seem to doubt you
need that you need the the punishments
of hell in order to be kind of bullied
into line in order to do the right thing
and that seemed to be very condescending
view of humanity yeah III worry that I'm
being on generous here because I am you
know commenting on people who I disagree
with but it seems worse than ungenerous
to me it seems horrifying the idea that
without this eternal damnation in this
in this particular case you know there's
no reason to be a good person and that
makes me think like really you don't you
can't think of any other reasons to be a
good person other than that because if
you confess to be an atheist and if you
impolite or even polite company people
will say well how
why why you're doing good then why don't
you why didn't you just go to motor
somebody because there's no you don't
have to worry about any punishment in
the afterlife well I you know most
people don't want to murder people
that's just they just I like to think
that yeah yeah I think and I mean you're
you know you the thing I liked about
your quoting that in your essay against
daughter was why is it no concept of
parole why is why is it your life is
only 80 years but your punishment is
eternal
it's just seem disproportionate well it
does but even more even for heaven the
same the same argument goes I think that
the people who come up with these ideas
their imaginations we're all finite
human beings it's just very hard to
stretch our imaginations to truly
embrace infinity or eternity in that way
there's how can you even be happy and
content in heaven for infinity years is
something I don't I did a very brief
chapter as a detour to heaven but this
the writings historical writings on Hell
are much more interesting and
comprehensive than writings on heaven
which which have a few and banal and
it's at the at its best and the kept
coming across this a description of
heaven as the throne of God surrounded
by holy angels singing holy holy holy is
the Lord our God day and night forever I
mean to me I they used to say the devil
has the best music but he also has a
much better story to tell them that I
mean everyone agrees that the inferno is
much more interesting to read than the
Paradiso right when it comes to Dante
there's it it is I think it's a there's
a it's a broader thing going on which is
that human beings tend to underwrite the
extent to which life is about change and
process right they think there's
something perfectible about life and
this is whether you're Buddhist or
Catholic or whatever and the idea is to
reach that perfect state and stay there
and I think that you know as a
naturalist myself
accepting that life is about flux and
change and impermanence is a much more
a realistic way to go and yet most
religions are believers in
perfectibility I mean even there was
those who are who do not have an eternal
eternal punishment and don't have in
heaven
you know the idea is to work your way
through various incarnations until you
have completely purge yourself of bad
doing and then you have become one with
the universe and you have become
perfectible and there's nowhere else to
go the regions don't really get into
what happens then because there is
really no then then there's nowhere to
go what's your perfectible then what
yeah and so I guess there's one final
thought from my side it you know it's
interesting you say talking about being
an atheist in polite company because
there is such a thing there's there is
an idea of what polite company is right
it you know we get it on TV and in the
media and there's certain ideas that are
taken for granted and both sides of any
one debate complain that they're
extremist view is not represented in
polite company I do think that you know
the sort of media approved version of
what is polite and okay says that being
atheist is worse than being religious
but it also says you shouldn't be really
religious right I mean it would mock you
if you believed too directly in Satan
hell and demonic possession even though
most people do believe that I think
fundamentalism in that sense is not
polite company itself yes I think people
do not like extreme positions I think
social compromises are necessary but I
still think it's it's more acceptable to
be slightly religious than it is to be
slightly unreligious yeah you can get
through all the words I think that's
changing pretty quickly I don't know the
new general newer generations seem to be
retreating pretty rapidly from that at
least from the organized Church gift not
from spirituality itself well the great
thing about polite company is that it
reverses itself all the time and
pretends it never has right and it does
that's a universal change you're right
yes that's true so I do you know I am
pretty optimistic I'm pretty
optimistic is a sense of prediction but
I'm interested in the fact that people
who don't have any religious affiliation
are growing as a set of people but I've
learned now from looking at things from
your book that the side of people who
believe in Satan is also increasing
dramatically so I'm gonna have to try to
understand that better that's a little a
little concerning to me and the notion
that exorcisms have been returning to
two popular cultures and is an
interesting thing to me yeah because
demonic possession it's not naturally
Satan but it's there are people who
suddenly believe in that and I was
fascinated to learn that you could
actually now book an exorcist online
their number of them available for
freelance exorcisms and their business
seems to be flourishing a part of me has
respect for that like if you believe in
Satan and devils and demons and then why
not believe that they possess people and
you should get them exercise it's almost
worse to me if you sort of profess
belief in that but not really right I
would like I like consistency and okay
for profess belief and then believe it's
impossible to changing it you had rid of
them that would be even more depressing
well that would be depressing yeah all
right but so it's a mixed message here
but Marc de villiers thanks so much for
being on the podcast thank you very much
Sean
[Music]